when i first learned about how accurate
alpha fall was
i thought that it could help us solve
the problem that we had been stuck with
for 10 years
sometimes you get this events in nature
where bacteria can acquire resistance to
a multitude of antibiotics and then
something that was harmless can become a
huge problem
with modern medicine and modern
antibiotics we kind of take it for
granted that we're not going to die of a
bacterial infection but there's 2.8
million antibiotic resistant infections
in the united states alone
it's pretty scary
the industry has not really generated
very many new antibiotics lately an
alternative approach to try to deal with
the problem of antibiotic resistance is
to try to develop approaches to defeat
the resistance mechanism so that the
existing antibiotics are affected
there's a couple different ways that
bacteria can acquire resistance in the
case that we're studying they modify the
bacteria membrane to prevent the
antibiotic from even getting in our
project is focused on understanding the
enzymes that allows the bacteria to
modify the membrane an important aspect
is that we also focus on understanding
the the structure of these enzymes but
those are particularly difficult to work
with because we need to take them out of
their natural environment we essentially
purify each one of these enzymes so that
you can obtain a pure sample free of all
other proteins the most common
techniques to determine the structure is
x-ray crystallography proteins in the
membranes of cells are notoriously
extremely difficult to crystallize
we had been able to obtain crystals that
diffracted x-rays for one of these
proteins that bda antibiotic resistance
but we had not been able to solve the
structure we had not been able to solve
the problem to be able to process the
crystallography data you need a model
which is a rough guess of what you think
the protein is going to look like
with technology like alpha fold which
provides a starting model that we can
combine with our data we'll be able to
solve these structures so much faster
i was just astonished at how accurate
the prediction was how was it that we
were 10 years unable to
to solve this and now we have this
prediction and you know solved in 30
minutes
so this is the case where um alpha fall
then gave us the overall structure of
the protein
now we can then move on to use this
structural information to try to
understand how the protein catalyzes its
chemistry
we know that there's a whole pathway of
enzymes involved in the antibiotic
resistance and if we stop just one of
those enzymes we'll be able to shut down
the mechanism
a tool like alpha fall is really poised
to have a huge impact in our ability to
develop new drugs
this could help solve the problem of
antibiotic resistance